حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك لواء فايز دويري
باعتقادك كيف من شان الدبابات التي يجري
دراسه تسليمها الى اوكرانيا من قبل
بريطانيا الان ان تغير في موازين القوى
من المعدات هي مصممه اصلا
للادوار التعرضيه الهجوميه ولكن يمكن
استخدامها في الادوار الدفاعيه وبالتالي
هذا يعتبر تجاوز للخطوط الحمراء اي في
البدايه كان فقط لتمكين الجيش الاوكراني
من الدفاع عن نفسه ضد الهجمات الروسيه
الان لا ستزود وتم الاقرار وهناك بحث ما
بين بولندا والمانيا من اجل الدبابات
الثقيله اذا دعيني اقول هو تجاوز الخطوط
الحمراء وهذا يعني الشيء الكثير لكن ماذا
ستقدم ماذا ستقدم تعتمد على امرين الامر
الاول الاعداد التي ستقدم هناك 50 عربات
برادلي 40 عربه
10 دبابات بريطانيه اييه رقم لم يحدد بعد
قد يكون بحجم سريع اي ام اكس 10 ولكن هذه
الاعداد متواضعه نعم تحدث فارق تعطي
القدره على شان هجمات تعرضيه محدوده ولكن
اذا كان ال ال الغايه من هذا التزويد هو
من اجل تاهيل الجيش الاوكراني لهجوم
الربيع القادم علينا ان نتحدث عن مضاعفه
هذه الارقام
بلا اقول بعشرات المرات على الاقل لتكون
بحجم كثير من كله بدات الحديث بالقول ان
هذا سيشكل تجاوزا للخطوط الحمراء ما نوع
هذا التجاوز ولماذا تقدم عليها الدول
الغربيه باعتقادك
لماذا هناك الجمله من الاسباب هناك اسباب
سياسيه وهناك اسباب اقتصاديه واسباب
اجتماعيه الاسباب السياسيه اعتقد ان الامر
يتعلق بالجانب العملي الامريكي لماذا لانه
الان اييي انقضاء عام 2023 يعني
توقيت فارغ البدء بالتحذير للانتخابات
الرئيس مقبله اذا دعيني اقول يحاول الحزب
الديمقراطي ان يقدم كل ما يستطيع تقديمه
من اجل انهاء هذه الحرب سواء بالتفاوض او
همم بجبار روسيا على تقديم تنازلات بالبعد
الاقتصادي الكلي يعلم ماذا يجري الان في
الدول الاوروبيه من حيث ارتفاع اسعار
المحروقات او اسعار الطاقه بصوره عامه
والاضرابات التي بدات تحدث في بريطانيا
وفرنسا وغيرها وبالتالي لابد من تقصيره
حمد الحرب في البعد الاجتماعي عمليات
المهاجرين
الطرف الروسي يقول ان كل هذه الاسلحه لن
تغير في موازين القوى الى اي مدى هذا
الامر واقعيا باعتقادك باختصار لو سمحت
دبابات كتيبه عربات برادلي كتيبه اي ام
اكس ستحدث تغييرا جوهريا وفارقا وستبكن
القوات الاخرانيه من شن هجمات تعرضيه وقد
لا افاجا ان يهاجموا من خلال سبولوجيا
ملاتوبيل اذا ما توفر هذه الاعداد
العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من عمان